every single week the government comes
out and they're like yo
here's some aliens we think it's aliens
or ufos or whatever like that and people
don't care
why do we not care about aliens anymore
and why do they keep trying to shove
ufos down our throats
when you look at all those quote ufos
and devices that are doing mach 15 the
rest of it
clearly we've got a lot of advanced
technologies and the word is those are
human technologies and basically the
deep state
the shadow government the breakaway
civilization
it is showing us the advanced technology
it's got and then trying to create an
ethos
to unify us around the threat of an
alien invasion and it was back at the
evian bilderberg group meeting in the
early 1990s
that henry kissinger later confirmed the
statement said we need an outside threat
from outside our planet to unify us
so they also have a project bluebeam
they've talked about of a fake alien
invasion using holograms
to basically get us to all unify around
that so if if kovan which is a real
virus but the hype and fear on it was
the you know the power grab the hoax
the fear was the hoax the shutdown was
the hoax then imagine an alien invasion
of what they could do with that and all
the pre-programming so yes
they're definitely trying to get us to
do that but you think that they're gonna
sorry go
well then why are we so divided in so
many other way like it feels like united
on this ufo [ __ ] we don't care
yeah that's the only yeah they're out
here going this is the newest thing
this is the news jordan is dropping
tuesday and we're like we don't need
that but the [ __ ] we're divided on
masks whatever we're very passionate
about those passionate about coving we
don't care about ufos bro we don't well
that's because we've been hearing about
it so much in movies at all bars but
there's definitely stuff going on this
planet
i think there's definitely advanced
civilizations that do come to the planet
but all that stuff you see those are
like weapon systems and things they have
yeah that's our [ __ ]
right yeah we're looking at our [ __ ] but
you do believe in the inner dimensions
that's showing the russians and the
chinese like
oh the aliens are here yeah that's what
i thought it was i thought it's us
flexing for them
we're gonna call it aliens but y'all
know what the [ __ ] it is yeah we just
surrounded our own ships there's not a
problem
because they want to surround theirs
they might shoot like oh your jet's
going to catch us at mach 3.
how about mach 20. that's the same deal
yeah
aliens never surround a chinese ship
yeah they never surround a russian ship
and they always say [ __ ] like there's
nothing that could possibly move that
fast
so you know that's how fast our [ __ ] is
yeah
i'm saying like that you can't even
comprehend how fast it is it's not even
possible for something to move that fast
is it but if it's our [ __ ] maybe it's
that fast
oh it's definitely our [ __ ] you got to
ask why is the u.s so advanced for
everybody else like we have like this
whole fake economy and oh we're oil
and oh we can't do anything oh meanwhile
it's like
i mean it's way advanced 30 40 years of
advance what do you mean what do you
mean by that
well speaking of israel did you see the
footage in the whole
latest gaza conflict where you'd see
like one missile hit a building the
whole thing falls down
that's not how that works so they've got
like these guided systems that go in
and it's it's like specially programmed
shaped charges
that like basically create some type of
barometric blast wave
and then take out everything that that's
like 40 year old technology
so the israelis are like now you usually
have to like drop a bunch of bombs on
like a
10-story building bring it down and be a
big big 20-story building
the the al jazeera headquarters well a
missile shoots in the side
and the whole building comes and a
little explosion also the building goes
yeah and then like a jet the jet flies
over shoots one missile in a building
the whole thing falls
that's like 40 year old stuff so now
they got stuff
way worse man they've got waves they can
hit that just like make
atoms divide they've got satellites like
one satellite just go just vaporize new
york for once
so that's why it's way advanced now you
see they
well then why is china popping off then
why don't we let them know what time it
is well they got some crazy [ __ ] too
like us no i mean they got i don't know
but they got some [ __ ]
but like us like take the space program
everybody sees fake stuff if you try to
fly
because they put fake productions out
they have all sorts of advanced stuff
they don't want to tell you that the
first 20 crews went to the moon or
whatever died
like you like like wait wait wait wait
what 20
you ever seen the movie first man no no
it's excellent but it's about the space
program
oh okay and and it shows up but they had
a bunch of programs i thought that was
like a coming out of the closet
well that too but you know no seriously
yeah it's it's first man on the moon but
the point is that's all real because
computers transmitting and
geeks on the ground can't make it as
good as a human you know dead reckoning
and they did
all those landings on earth with gravity
much stronger like there's
there's 35 millimeter footage of buzz
aldrin and and uh
and uh what's the big guy uh neil neil
armstrong
flying around in those landers and
taking office
i mean they did all that on earth and
they had like almost died like nine
times already
scrapped little program an alarm frame
refused that's all in the movie it's
accurate mm-hmm
like like doing those things where you
have to fly in from he'd have to take
off up a mile up and then act like he
was coming to the moon landing
but that but they did all that stuff but
before them there was a that's why the
guys would never brag and stuff
they want to take credit because so many
people died in quote
accidents like like back then they'd say
oh did you hear four of the astronauts
died flying into florida at an airport
oh sure they died the helicopter
actually they were dying in helicopter
accidents they were dying in secret
space stations
because they couldn't have it fail up
there so the first measures had to be
other guys
those weren't the first guys so someone
else landed on the moon
came back and then they let buzz
lightyear and uh
what's his name again yeah
that's what i'm getting at is is that is
that
thousands died the u.s test pilot
project in the 50s and 60s
well it all went in the space program
that it was all secret after that so the
whole shadow government was nasa after
that point
and so nasa is like the whole breakaway
government and i don't want to get too
conspiratorial but isn't nasa made up of
nazis
well the nazis did found nasa um bernard
von braun the goddard space center all
of them so
are you telling our shadow government is
nazis
isn't that the whole i mean i think
they're like guys for hire because
here's an example egypt hired some nazi
scientists
that's a famous israeli case they had to
go all over the middle east and europe
and kill
all the egyptian scientists you know
heard about story all the egyptian
scientists that had gotten the nazi
technology
so the germans were just selling to
everybody but then it goes back to
question why did they have all these
plans nobody else did
these are the interdimensional that's
what hitler was doing yeah
and i'm not even into that that's what
they said it was happening they had this
bell project
that they came up with they got from the
tibetans or whatever some
interdimensional deal
and if you went in it you like got
psychic and like these things told you
what to do
so it was like dmt without the drugs i
don't know if all that's real
i just asked why to the germans because
germans are smart but like the russians
just want everybody smart why did they
have all the rockets [ __ ] nobody else
did
yeah because their technology was far
more advanced the space they've been
jets everything the space shuttle
was something vernervon regular was like
1937.
like respect 30s the space shuttle's a
whole sketch whole nine yards when does
the model t come out
1909 i mean that's crazy you're talking
about less than
30 years after the car
unbelievable so so you're saying there's
some outside influence for that for sure
the nazis on record thought they were
getting it from the occult
and they were doing all sorts of weird
[ __ ] i mean it's like you're obsessed
with that in bavaria
yeah and the wright brothers were in
1903
put in perspective because wright
brothers are 1903
the the germans have jets by 40.
they just couldn't mass-produce they
have jets by 40. we're not talking about
regulations in service by 43. understand
we're in space before we have jets
well that's what they call the space
shuttle yeah the space shuttle is called
silver bird okay
like you've seen hollywood puts in
movies you see the first captain america
where red skulls find that big bomber to
brown new york
that was a real plan they had a they had
a space shuttle they were building when
it got blown
up in like germany and under underground
base i've read all the names
and it was gonna have three nukes in it
they were gonna bomb new york chicago
and seattle
because that was the way the silver bird
was gonna fly it was a space shuttle
and it was gonna have three atomic bombs
that they were gonna drop but the u.s
went over
with the british and wanted to destroy
those underground bases that's even a
mainline history
swear to god type in nazi space shuttle
silver bird
yeah lots of species the v1 rocket oh
yeah the v1 the v7 yeah
what does that be one and the visa
they're talking like you know rockets
that were shooting over at england it's
like the first cruise missile
and you think that they got this
information from
the occult or inter-dimensional i don't
think that like we see raiders are lost
ark that's based on real stuff hitler
like lost the war because he had so many
archaeologists and troops all over
africa
all over the middle east all over tibet
digging shut up he had all these tibetan
monks in like castles like channeling
[ __ ]
and telling his science what to do so
hitler believed in all that stuff wait
that's true it's in mainline history
yeah you don't really see it on
discovery channel but
it's all it's it's all in the mainland
history yeah and where did the razer's
lost art came from
it's not like he was actually trying to
dig all that stuff up the lost ark the
the rock of the covenant
there's like wisdom within these things
yeah but he mainly did what the tibetan
monks told him they
they weren't like nazis they were just
like telling me what their big secrets
so he shipped a bunch back to germany
and they were like telling him what is
that what china hates to bet so much
that's where they got the swastika from
well they got it from india india and
india has it too but that's a that's a
that's a buddhist symbol
the hindu symbol [ __ ]
all of this is a sun symbol it doesn't
mean anything bad but i mean the point
is is it
that's where he got it was from asia and
do you think that he was contacting the
occult before he decided that they were
going to take over the world it said
mainline history books they don't put on
discovery channel
that they had like this ss castle where
they would cut off ss officers heads
and they believed like it would give
them psychic power and stuff just
whacked out dude i just
i think of it as psycho behavior but
like why is jeffrey epstein at zorro
ranch trying to impregnate women for the
super race
these rich dudes just go crazy and they
just get on this power trip with their
god they just do all this crazy stuff
i don't care if it's a chinese i don't
care if it's the russians i don't care
if it's the u.s
i don't care all these scientists go
[Applause]
crazy
you